right now to a potentially revolutionary
breakthrough in creating clean
essentially Limitless energy later today
the department of energy and scientists
from a federal nuclear weapons facility
plan to announce a long sought
achievement that someday may lead to a
massive source of carbon-free
electricity Lilly Luciano spoke to
scientists to say this is a game changer
in the effort to prevent climate change
it's the Holy Grail of energy creation
that some say could save humans from
Extinction nuclear fusion it combines
two hydrogen atoms which then makes
helium and a whole lot of energy
scientists from the Lawrence Livermore
National Laboratory in California are
expected to announce today that they've
achieved a net energy gain for the first
time in history the day you get more
energy out of it than you put in
sky is the limit nuclear fusion is how
stars like our sun generate power yes
and the news has astrophysicists Neil
deGrasse Tyson very excited we've known
how to fuse atoms and generate energy we
just haven't been able to control it
nuclear fusion technology has been
around since the creation of the
hydrogen bomb but using that technology
to harness energy has required Decades
of research they took 200 laser beams
some of the most powerful on the planet
Earth converge that energy down to a
pellet a pellet the size of a BB and
just remember fusion power has no
nuclear waste to speak of no meltdowns
to worry about current nuclear power
plants use fission which breaks apart
atoms to create energy even though it's
not burning fossil fuel meltdowns like
Chernobyl and Fukushima are evidence
that nuclear fission can still harm
humans and our environment
but now Fusion's moment appears to be
finally here we're long overdue who have
converted something so destructive that
finally it could be used for a peaceful
purpose in the service of civilization
for CBS mornings I'm Lilia Luciano
okay that's a big deal uh well if Neil
deGrasse Tyson is excited every big name
in science and physics without there
being like this is a big deal this is a
big deal and I think it means at the end
of the day when you flip the light
switch the lights still go on so that's
also good we like that cleaning or
something but you do make a good point
when you see the scientists excited of
course and Neil you could feel his
enthusiasm through the TV screen